Our civilization climbs from the ashes.
The coming generations will have something to build upon.
But it isn’t just knowledge we’d be saving...
but humanity’s story.
Our story.
I know what it feels like to be left alone.
I will not abandon that boy.
I think that’s what it’s all about.
Being brave. Embracing change.
Where we went today, was it real?
Or was it my imagination?
I love you.
My family is the reason…
I’m the way I am.
Why is it such a big secret?
We make the move. Make the move.
And we start again.
I have this noise in my head.
It’ll stop.
One day it’ll go quiet.
You are the bassline.
Without you there’s no song.
At last the night has ended…
And so, a new day dawns!
I'm doing good huh?
Real good.